cuando graphic amos nos podemos
enfrentar a diversos tipos de funciones
seguro ya has visto funciones y gráficas
de primer y segundo grado recuerdas cómo
son en el caso de las de primer grado
las representamos con una recta como
ésta
cuando gráfica mos funciones de segundo
grado que da una curva bastante regular
pero te imaginas qué características
tienen las gráficas de tercer o cuarto
grado
veamos cómo son y qué propiedades
geométricas tienen cuando las gráfica
moss recuerda que las funciones de
tercer grado también les podemos decir
cúbicas tenemos la siguiente gráfica de
la función fx igual a equis a la tercera
potencia menos cinco y en esta tabla
tenemos los valores con los que ese
gráfico
que puedes identificar en esta gráfica
fíjate muy bien a diferencia de las
funciones de primer y segundo grado
cuando tenemos una gráfica de una
función de tercer grado podemos notar
que se ponen un poco locas y tienen más
onda
pero a qué crees que se deba pues como x
está elevada a la potencia 3 f x crece
bastante rápido y genera una curva muy
larga y un poco pegada al eje de fx
ahora si las gráficas de funciones de
tercer grado se ponen locas y crecen
rápido como crees que sean las de cuarto
grado si están más elevadas yo creo que
son más locas tenemos este ejemplo uy no
me equivoque está más loca porque f x
crece más rápido y forma una curva
achatada con estas líneas que son casi
rectas
pero cuidado no te confundas con las
curvas de segundo grado son diferentes
porque las de segundo grado son más
regulares y las de 4º grado son más
exponenciales
algo que debes de saber es que cuando
tengas la gráfica de una función elevada
a la cuarta potencia jamás tendrás
valores negativos es decir no pasará por
debajo del eje x ya que el resultado de
una potencia par siempre es positivo
por el contrario como las de tercer
grado son potencias impar hay valores
positivos y negativos mira
pongamos las dos gráficas en el mismo
plano para que puedas darte cuenta de
las propiedades que comentamos con esto
ya sabrás identificar cuál de todas
tiene más onda